so my name is Arthur and I work on the
cloud gateway team in Netflix and our
primary responsibility is building and
maintaining Zhul and Zul primarily
routes traffic to all of our micro
services and we have a lot of micro
services you may have seen this picture
before this is a map of our streaming
related micro services so only the
streaming related micro services not all
the other stuff we do and this is the
flow of traffic among them so it comes
from the Internet through the EO B's
goes through multiple Zul clusters those
dual clusters route traffic to our
back-end services mainly our API and
then to our mid tiers and you'll humor
you'll hear me use the word origin a lot
and origin essentially is our
terminology for downstream service so
when I say origin that's what I'm
talking about the service that Zul is
gonna rap to so this is pretty
impressive right here's the thing though
this picture is actually several years
old since then some major services have
been you know sharded and decomposed
into smaller ones there are also more
business functions and product features
that we've added and and that creates
you know more new services we've also
started using containers and this is
great for developers it makes it really
easy to spin up a new service and do
something new but for every container
every environment every different
configuration this creates a new route
for Zul and very quickly the system
starts looking more like this so over
time the amount of backends that Zul
talks to has exploded and it'll probably
continue to do so in the future now it's
important to keep in mind that each one
of these dots is a service so it could
be composed of potentially hundreds of
instances
and dozens of critical metrics that win
we may need to sift through just to see
what's going on so when we inevitably
run into production incidents we need to
root cause them as fast as possible when
we had just a handful of origins
it was mostly doable but now it's like
finding a needle in a haystack we have
to sift through dozens and dozens of
dashboards to figure out what's going on
and where so imagine getting a page at
3:00 in the morning you roll over you
grab your laptop and you try and find
that one needle in this massive massive
haystack not easy right it's pretty
clear to us that we needed a solution to
help us root cause these incidents more
effectively we've always had alerts
based on static percentage based metric
thresholds and the problem with these
alerts is that they're broad and the
thresholds are set very high so that we
don't get a lot of false positives so
you may not catch certain anomalies that
are very specific to your service or
just too low to hit that threshold
they're also slow because they have to
go through this huge time series
database that serves the whole company
you may not get your alert until 10
minutes later like in this graph so you
can see the threshold gets crossed and
then only 10 minutes later we get an
alert so a lot of stuff can happen in 10
minutes especially when you're dealing
with massive scale another problem is
these alerts would only be specific to
our service so we'd only get alerts for
Zul and not for other services that may
be having trouble and since we're in the
front door we'd be getting alerts for
everyone's services error rates go up
for downstreams a rates go up for us so
an example here the top graph and the
bottom graph are identical one is Xul's
error rate the other one is a specific
origins area
you look at the dashboard you know five
ten minutes you figure out pretty
quickly okay this is this is the problem
here so this created an operational
burden for us and you know we wanted to
offload that and what we ended up doing
is building a real-time anomaly
detection system it has dynamic
thresholds and we run them for every
metric and every grouping of different
clusters and origins and essentially it
creates this adaptive threshold that
follows the metric we then take all
those anomaly detection across all of
those slices and when one of them is
anomalous we know exactly which origin
is in trouble because we've sliced it by
that origin or that dual cluster to know
what's going on so then we compile all
these anomalies into a time line and
send it out to the responsible or
on-call operators we named our anomaly
detector raju and you know it's kind of
a neat acronym but realistically we
named it after a former colleague whose
name is Raju and he was famous at the
company for like being so in tune with
every metric that he could like just
jump in and figure out what's going on
he was like it's like he was living
inside the computer so these alerts they
can pinpoint basically which system is
in trouble when create a time line of
events and this creates kind of a causal
relationship that helps us figure out
which system is the root cause of all
the problems and we were blown away by
the results we saw so we've grown to
rely on them pretty heavily and it's
significantly reduced our operational
burden for example our team used to get
ten pages a week now we're down to about
one page a week or less so that's that's
a huge improvement for us that's a
massive win and helps us sleep at night
you know literally and the other big win
here is that it's in real-time so we can
detect these alerts sometimes before our
pagers fire and sometimes before metrics
show up on our dashboards
and we built all this without any fancy
AI there's no machine learning it's just
some elegant math some statistics and
some algorithms that help us solve some
very hard problems so let's get into how
we built it first I'm going to talk
about why static alerts suck why they
didn't work for us how we use real-time
event processing and then how we use
those real-time events to do anomaly
detection and then finally how to filter
out the anomalies that don't matter and
make the alerts actually useful so
static alerts suck and the biggest the
biggest thing we needed was speed speed
is critical let me give you an example
we have a small incident and incident
happens at zero minutes so we have to
wait for our metrics to catch up let's
say we're five minutes in and the pager
fires somebody gets paged usually it was
Zul so the zhulong call you know it
might take them 10 minutes to get out of
bed and get their laptop they respond
within 10 minutes so already 15 minutes
deep before we even looked at anything
finally if it's a you know if it's a
minor incident the zhulong call can dig
through the metrics and you know maybe
they can figure it out in 15 minutes and
then they realize that it's actually a
downstream system that didn't get paged
because we didn't have that visibility
so now the zhulong call has to page the
downstream on call again we have to wait
for the downstream own call to respond
then they look through some metrics if
they're really lucky they can identify
that issue in 10 minutes and then if
they're even luckier if it's like a
config change they can fix it in five
minutes so this best case scenario still
takes about 50 minutes to resolve and
the first 30 minutes of that is just
figuring out who to page this is this is
very problematic speed when resolving is
this these incidents is very critical
so most metrics collection solutions
like time series databases they're
solving a very comprehensive problem for
the whole company and they tend to be
pretty slow for example at Netflix we're
processing like a billion metrics per
minute and what we want to look at is a
much narrower slice in that in a much
faster way so when these events happen
it takes at least five to ten minutes
those metrics to catch up we also use
rolling counts on our alarms or sorry
our alerts so that we don't get false
positives so for example you want to see
that you've passed that threshold nine
out of the last ten minutes before you
send an email so you're not constantly
emailing people for like minor blitz and
then each time you page another team you
create that loop so if you have to page
several teams in that investigation it's
gonna take a very long time to figure
out the root cause and all these things
put together mean we have much slower
resolutions which has a massive massive
impact this is a graph of essentially
extrapolated impact of incidents over
time so when we built a lot of these
systems let's say five years ago we
could have a two-hour outage which today
would be equivalent to a five-minute
outage so a lot of these tools aren't
really solving the problems that we're
having today and we're actually trending
even further so a five minute impact is
just as big as a two hour outage five
years ago that's that's insane right and
maybe in ten years it'll be like one
minute or 30 seconds or whatever but
let's let's not get ahead of ourselves
so obviously over time it's becoming
more and more critical to resolve these
incidents as fast as possible the other
thing we need is context so alerts fire
on a single metric for a single app
that's set up by that specific team and
they don't really get to look at other
team's alerts and typically when an SRE
sees that there's a huge out
they'll page all the suspects they'll
page everyone that could potentially be
involved so that they don't have to go
through that loop of paging every
downstream over and over again which
means that if you're the front door like
us we get paged all the time so we
needed to show the what the where and
the when in the alert so that the
operators could orient themselves and
figure out who needs to be paged we also
need accuracy as I showed you in that
previous graph that the static
thresholds don't necessarily catch all
the anomalies and they're set for only
these obvious high impact issues that
happen you know at a very high scale and
that may not necessarily be enough so we
need more adaptive thresholds and then
selfishly for us we wanted to reduce our
operational burden we were constantly
getting paged and that creates alert
fatigue after a while you have to go
through all these dashboards when you
get paged and that created very
difficult on-call rotations for us and
as I mentioned our page load is about 10
a week and we wanted to get that down so
what's the solution
real-time alerting combining several
anomalies into one alerts so we can see
which which systems are the pattern here
and then orient the operators so they
can page the exact team and not every
team so let's talk about how we do
real-time events so for stream
processing we use a framework called
mantis and mantis is used essentially to
collect and process real-time events you
can think of it as like Kafka Plus
Apache flink put together and all the
critical services at Netflix send events
into mantas not just zoo to give you a
sense of scale just for Zul we send
millions of events per second across all
like all the thousands of devices that
we have and each one of those events has
hundreds of dimensions so
mantis is incredibly useful for allowing
us to kind of search and sip to those
events and just pick out the slice that
we need for all of our real-time traffic
and then we can do it on demand so it
doesn't necessarily need to push the
vents all the time we can submit a query
and it'll just match the query and
return the results here's how it works
so imagine we have all the Zul clusters
which are you know hundreds and hundreds
of instances we have a big mantas job
called the Mantis request source and it
opens an SSE socket to every single Zul
instance then we have downstream jobs
that want specific functionality
specific parts of that request source so
a certain subset and they submit queries
through the request source into Zhul Zul
will find all the things that match and
then send that back to the request
source and the request source will
multiplex it to all the jobs that are
interested in that event so some of the
big features the first one is querying
so you can submit sequel style queries
and get results back on that you can
sample any portion of traffic so you
could do one percent of traffic ten
percent you can do a hundred percent if
you want to and aside from anomaly
detection this is an incredibly useful
framework just for debugging production
is in so you can see exactly what a
certain type of event looks like right
now going through the servers we also
use mantis for stream processing so that
mantis job that's getting a stream of
events can actually run some arbitrary
code every time it gets an event so you
can think of it as like a mapping
function it also allows us to aggregate
so we can build complex result sets in
real time we can aggregate by any key in
that highly dimensional space and
ultimately allows us to reduce those
large result sets into kind of useful
aggregates and then lastly job chaining
is very important so we can take a bunch
of these mapping functions we can chain
them together we can pipe them into
these reduce functions
we could end up with a really really
useful result set and make some
interesting decisions which is what raju
does so now for the good stuff how do we
do anomaly detection we had some
requirements the biggest one it needs to
be cheap enough that we can do it in
real time it needs to be stable enough
that we can did we can detect sharp
spikes and recover from them and then
still dynamic enough that it will adjust
to neutrons over time and then lastly we
wanted to have it somewhat lenient so we
don't get a lot of false positives so we
tried a handful of algorithms like
double exponential smoothing which had
historical analysis like week over week
but the solution we eventually came to
is median estimation so the median is a
robust indicator which means it doesn't
get skewed when there's a huge outlier
it stays very stable and it's it's
really cheap to calculate now you might
be wondering how do you calculate a
median on streaming data you don't have
the whole distribution how do you have
the median well that brings me to our
median estimation algorithm or as I call
it the kodi algorithm named after my
colleague Cody because he came up with
it it's actually called mad or median
absolute deviation I believe and it's
effectively just a stochastic gradient
descent with a static learning rate so
if a streaming value comes in and it's
greater than a median estimate then we
increase our median estimate by one if a
streaming value comes in and it's less
than our median estimate then we
decrease the median value by one so very
simple very cheap but surprisingly
effective here's the here's a graph from
Raju and the red line is the metric and
the blue line is a threshold and you can
see the metric is very noisy it's gone
up and down up and down up and down and
the threshold is very stable but it
still follows along so as that spiky
metric goes up
the threshold slowly goes up and as a
spiky metric drops the threshold slowly
drops but it's very stable and that's
because that learning rate is static and
it's it's one so it's learning very
slowly and and that's that's a big
feature because when you get this which
is very common for outages is metrics
that go from zero to a thousand or 8,000
in this case that threshold doesn't
overcorrect
it doesn't chase that error metric too
fast so it remains very stable and
eventually when that error metric drops
back down to zero you can see that the
thresholds not too far up and it can
recover pretty quickly whereas with some
other algorithms it would go to from 0
to 8,000 and now your thresholds like
blown-out for an hour and then when it
recovers it's blowing out for another
hour because it's like negative now so
stability big feature it's also it's
also very simple right which produces a
simple code base and predictable
behavior and again very cheap to
calculate over thousands and thousands
of metrics and all these permutations of
cluster origin and combinations so
that's that's incredibly important the
other feature that we really wanted was
recovery detection it's critical to see
if an alert is ongoing or if it's
transient right it's if you wake up in
the morning you don't necessarily want
to get out of bed if this thing is
recovered already right and if it
recovers in a couple minutes then you're
probably okay to go back to sleep
it also prevents action right if you
know something's recovered it's going to
mitigate action without you having to
figure out if it's recovered or not so
you're not gonna have to go scale
something up or scale something down or
push a new build or whatever and then it
gives you some info right if it spiked
and recovered quickly that's information
that's useful to figuring out what the
problem is and since we're building this
timeline of events we have this open
window for anomalies we could
potentially recover before we've sent
the email in which case we don't need to
send the email at all
how do we detect recovery well it's
pretty simple we calculate the pre alert
range which is our kind of stable metric
and then we look at the recent range and
we have to confidently be able to say
that the recent range is the same
distribution as the pre alert range if
that's true then we've recovered but
again this is harder than it sounds for
streaming data because you don't have
the entire set you need to find a
heuristic that's useful for figuring out
what your boundary is and what we did
for that is we used the huffing bound
and you should take a picture of this
with your cell phones because this is
extremely useful streaming data this is
like a killer app for streaming data you
basically only have to give it the range
which is the max minus the min and the
set of numbers the size of the data set
that you have and it will give you some
boundary with confidence of epsilon so
if you play with that Delta the 1 minus
Delta there if you play with that Delta
you can kind of tweak it for your metric
and be fairly confident that your recent
points are in the same distribution as
your previous points so here's an
example you can see there's a
distribution in the bottom corner there
and depending on your Delta you're going
to be either very close to that
distribution or very far from that
distribution so you don't want to be too
close because then you'll you'll be not
leaning enough you don't be too far
because then you're gonna overshoot your
distribution and be way too lenient and
everything is going to look like a
recovery typically we've been pretty
happy with the delta of 0.1 which is
that 99% line and it's worked very well
for us so what does a recovery algorithm
look like it's a huffing bound on the
pre alert distribution we then take the
last 30 seconds of data points and get
the mean and then if the recent mean is
below that bound then we're good we've
recovered here's what it looks like on a
graph so usually the error rate is flat
and in some
thing happens there eight spikes we have
our pre alert range now we're anomalous
and then it starts tapering off slowly
and depending what kind of algorithm
you're using like if you're calculating
slope or something like that you may
think you've recovered at one of those
two upper recovery ranges but in reality
you haven't really recovered until
you're back to that normal error rate
that you're used to so it's very
effective in that sense now these
anomalies happen all the time we don't
want to get flooded with emails right we
want to make sure we only get the emails
that are real problems and have a real
impact so first let's look at what Raju
really looks like so these boxes are the
chain of mantas jobs that compose Raju
and the size of the Box corresponds
roughly to how many containers are
required to run it so the duel request
source is huge it's hundreds of
containers because it has to be able to
handle potentially all of Xul's traffic
we then pipe it to an aggregator so some
aggregation query and this can be a much
smaller cluster maybe tens of instances
and produce a distilled aggregate once
we get that aggregate then we can have
like one instance clusters like the
anomaly detector and Raju are very small
because all they get is just aggregates
for the Zul aggregation it's pretty
simple we select the status for all
requests and then we aggregate all the
values of that status and we group them
by Zul cluster and destination origin we
then window it for ten seconds and we
output it a one-second interval so the
groupings that we end up with are the
Zul cluster the downstream origin and
then cluster and origin together in case
it's a very specific type of issue
we then take those groupings and we feed
them into that anomaly detector and what
it does is it flattens all of those
groupings into a big list sorry and we
take that big list and we run anomaly
detection on each item in that list so
each item that list is gonna have some
count and then if one of those counts is
anomalous we know exactly what's broken
you know it's that exact permutation of
cluster and origin that's in trouble
so recall this slide from earlier right
this is this is the representation of
all the different permutations that we
have and when one of them has that
anomalous metric we know right away it's
that guy here's the here's what the data
looks like this is a think of more
useful like this is this is like the
real explanation this is this is the
money of what it looks like right so you
have all these predictions coming in and
you can see it's color-coded a little
bit so on the Left we have the Zul
cluster as the grouping so it's all for
the same cluster but different values of
status so we have success we have read
time out we have throttling and then on
the right we have different groupings
like Zul cluster 2 and then cluster an
API put together just API and when one
of these is anomalous we know that it's
that cluster we know it's like Zul
cluster one has an anomalous count for
this value so we can say in the email
Zul cluster 1 is throttling traffic at
this rate
that's essentially you know it's it's
almost like root cause detection but
it's it's the very first step to that
root cause detection and you know this
is this is what makes it so powerful
this this this ability to dig down into
all these aggregates now most anomalies
aren't really anomalies right they
happen all the time
so we need to assess impact we need to
figure out is it recovered or not and
essentially filter out all the noise so
the way we did that is with
engine we open this window when the
first anomaly happens and we then
collect all the subsequent anomalies for
that window sighs and at the end of the
window we run this rules engine for each
anomaly and this rules engine basically
just tags every one of those anomalies
with a bunch of useful data once we get
all those tagged anomalies we can then
make an intelligent decision on what we
should do whether we shall learn we
should not alert things like that so an
example of some useful rules time very
important when of the alert happen when
of the alert recover impact also very
important if it doesn't impact any
traffic we don't care if it has a really
big impact that's very important so what
percent of traffic is erroneous versus
successful a description so when we send
the email to operators we don't
necessarily have to expect them to know
all of our status codes we want to
describe what the problem is and then
finally decisions on do we alert do we
not alert do we page do we not page and
these rules are all handwritten which is
somewhat time consuming but incredibly
accurate so as I mentioned we have this
timeline of events when the first
anomaly happens we start a window we
close the window after three minutes and
then we end up with this tagged timeline
so it's a very rich timeline of events
and what it ends up doing is creating
this time-based causation almost well
technically correlation but the
correlation is very strong because
things are happening in a very tight
window so you can figure out pretty
clearly what's going on and we can look
at some examples this is what a Roger
email looks like I know you can't see
anything on the slide it's very dense so
I'm gonna clean it up for you guys so
I've kind of simplified and renamed a
couple of the things so that you
actually know what they say instead of
like our internal Netflix names for
things in blue we have the Zul cluster
in green we have the downstream origin
in yellow slash orange we
the failure the failure status described
and then purple is the impact so you can
see the first thing that we get is this
grouping of Zul cluster so the Zul
website cluster and our API origin and
it's starting to have some connectivity
issues connectivity issues meaning like
we can't connect we're getting a
connection refused next thing that
happens is just that API service
grouping is now failing with timeouts
and then in a few seconds later just the
website grouping the website cluster is
also failing with timeouts then it gets
a little bit worse now Sewell is
throttling retries to that API service
and throttling retries essentially means
we're trying to prevent a retry storm so
instead of sending all the traffic to
this downstream origin and basically
taking it under water we're rejecting
anything that is tagged as a retry to
protect it but this is a pretty dire
situation so that this means that people
are probably not able to stream anything
at least for that cluster and then a
different Zul cluster which is the api
zuo api cluster which generally fronts
that api service as well is now also
throttling retries so another retry
storm and then finally just the cluster
grouping is throttling so it's pretty
clear here that the root cause is
somewhere in API right you have multiple
dual clusters having trouble talking to
this api service and the api service on
its own is also in trouble so even
though in the past you would have
potentially paged both Zul and api in
this case it's pretty clear it's not a
dual problem it's almost certainly an
API problem and this was this was a
powerful thing to see for us because we
can now point to this you know this
being the root cause and we can send
that directly to that team in fact it
was it was so successful that we wanted
to dig a little bit deeper and so we
expanded Raju into API as well
now let's take a step back and talk
about what API actually is at Netflix
it's called the API dot next platform if
some of you are aware of that or not
it's essentially an orchestration layer
so there are many device teams and those
device teams deploy their endpoints
which are basically groovy scripts for
the most part into this shared platform
and they use the platform code to do all
kinds of stuff all kinds of
functionality that goes downstream to
other services and that code is always
whatever function that service is doing
whether it's making a downstream or not
is gonna be wrapped in a history command
so those are the h's on that graph and
history is essentially a framework for
you know short-circuiting and isolating
traffic so it creates an isolation of
all these functions so that they so one
bad function basically doesn't take down
the entire server now there's there's so
much functionality here there's so much
stuff that API does that you end up with
hundreds and hundreds of these hystrix
commands and you guessed it it's another
needle in a haystack problem so this
seemed like another natural place where
we could put Raju so what we did is we
aggregated all the history response
codes and we group them by the command
name so the actual functionality of that
history command and API cluster that was
running on and then we basically threw
them on to the same timeline as all the
Zul anomalies so here's an example again
cleaned up for your viewing pleasure but
you can see there's now like a prefix on
the line that says which app it came
from so it's either API or Zul and the
API cluster is coded blue and then the
history command is coded or sorry
colored green so let's go through it we
have this incident and the first thing
that happens is this grouping of API
service which is that API origin
and this authenticate customer command
is suddenly failing and then just the
authentic a customer command is failing
which means it's probably happening
across multiple clusters you wait a
couple minutes and eventually it
escalates into Zul failing with the read
timeouts and it's the Zul api which is
the cluster fronting API and the api
origin so again pretty clear indicator
where the problem is and then the
website cluster and the website UI
service start failing and this is
because that website UI service has to
make some calls to API in order to
render the website starts throttling
requests failing with three timeouts and
then a related history command starts
failing which is get customer
permissions so in this case authenticate
customer get customer permissions all go
to the same origin that downstream of
API which is our subscriber service that
holds all that information and then
finally the Zulu API cluster across the
board is saying no more retries we're
throttling this retry storm so this is
problematic but you can see how powerful
this is right not only do we know that
the issues happening in API but we know
exactly which slice of functionality in
the API is broken so we know that okay
most likely our subscriber service is in
trouble so the operators with s Ari's
see this kind of email and they're not
gonna page Zul and they're not gonna
page api probably they're gonna page a
subscriber team so huge win huge win for
us and on top of that it's pretty clear
that you know what the root cause is
here right you can see the root cause
pretty pretty pretty easily just by
looking at this timeline of events so we
didn't stop there we expanded we expand
it to other types of events so events
that aren't anomalies but that we can
see happening now our gold standard
metric for a KPI so our
gold-standard indicator of is the system
good or not is the start play indicator
so how many star plays are we getting
per second if you can't play that means
we're in trouble right if you can't push
play and play a video that means we're
down most likely because it's it's a
very predictable cycle of our traffic so
in this example one of our DRM services
which is the PlayReady DRM it's
typically used for windows and streaming
sticks you can see that hystrix command
starts failing and then within about a
minute we get this SPS drop event for
the Windows app and the streaming stick
now this is this is mind blowing to us
right this is this is like insanely
powerful you're getting this SBS drop
event which we've had for years and
years but you're not only getting this
SBS drop event you're also getting what
caused the drop right so before you say
okay well Windows is down let's figure
it out now you're saying okay Windows is
down and it's because the DRM service is
broken here's another example so this
one is Zul instead of API but basically
we have this dual cluster that Front's
are a lot of our production traffic and
in this case it's fronting the iOS UI
service and services in trouble and then
again within about a minute iPhone iPod
and iPad get an SBS drop so you're
getting this SBS drop event for iOS
devices and guess what the iOS service
is in trouble let's page those guys we
took it another step further we added
spinnaker events and spinnaker is our
kind of deployment framework so in this
particular example again you see it's
not an SBS job but it's a push so
somebody pushes a service and then the
history command for that service breaks
a minute later so you get this email and
you can pretty quickly as the operators
say okay let's roll back that push it's
obviously broken and then finally you
know we have all this functionality now
but we don't want to get those pages we
don't want to get those email
so we start actually emailing the
culprits directly the origins sometimes
aren't aware of the issue if it's a
connectivity issue they may not even see
it in their metrics so this gives them
much better visibility into whether
their services in trouble or not and
then obviously if it recovers we'll send
them a followup with with the recovery
info so this ultimately reduced the need
for us to get paged on everything and
and it kind of pushes the onus onto the
teens that own the services that are in
trouble
so elephant in the room
machine learning right any for any black
mirror fans that's a crazy episode by
the way
so why didn't we use machine learning
well for this particular problem it
wouldn't have worked well right it's
very hard to train something when you
have very few examples of problems right
we don't have that many outages that we
can train this effectively and when we
do have outages they're all different
they don't we we don't have outages
because the same thing keeps happening
over and over again so it's very hard to
train a reinforcement type model and
because of that you'll have this huge
false positive rate and then the other
problem is even if you could get half of
the way there the data set will then
change and so whatever you've trained is
now useless because things don't look
the same after like a month or two
months things are always evolving and
looking different so some of the
benefits are you know we get the simple
predictable code base we have these
handwritten rules which have this really
high true positive rate and that's super
super important when you're dealing with
thousands and thousands of metrics and
all these different clusters and all
these different permutations if you had
a high false positive rate you would
never look at those alerts you'd be
getting like a hundred a second right
it's not useful so that high true
positive rate is very important but
obviously you know there's trade-offs
there it's not necessarily easy to
transfer a new service into Raju there's
a lot of hand-holding that has to happen
the rules need to be created manually as
I mentioned
the alerting decisions are potentially
different for every service so those may
need to be tweaked every time you add a
new service and then in order to do all
that stuff you need deep operational
knowledge and that comes at a premium so
you know pros and cons but we're pretty
happy with it
we built this real-time contextual
alerting system over thousands of
metrics millions of events per second
they go off super fast and they
sometimes even recover before our pagers
fire and they give us this rich timeline
of events that gives us deep insight
into our system and essentially help us
root cause a lot of incidents we've also
expanded into API and other services you
know for deeper insights and we continue
to do that and we're gonna continue to
expand Roger and make it more user
friendly to hopefully help onboarding
and things like that and ultimately we
did in a very simple way without any AI
and pretty happy with it that's it thank
you
[Applause]